well done draco
well done
when they're not evil they're often
pretty hilarious
from the slytherins we watched growing
up like draco crab and goyal to their
parents to dolores umbridge to voldemort
himself not a single actor managed to
get through filming without some flubs
we've got 15 of the best bloopers right
here
look at him
it's a hard life isn't it yeah i got him
number one
and that's how you describe a literal
child on set filming a movie about magic
tom felton giggled throughout most of
his time on set during the first film
any chance he could entertain the
cameras or flash a smile this boy was on
it a total showman from the very start
on malfoy
draco malfoy number two
rehearsing hard or hardly rehearsing
dolores umbridge a slytherin if we ever
saw one but imelda staunton wasn't
nearly as uptight during her time on set
especially when getting to hang out and
joke with the maggie smith blah blah
blah disloyalty oh
this slytherin actor saved the serious
stuff for when the cameras were rolling
number three
you've never seen cousins quite like
this before sirius and bellatrix have a
not so great familial relationship but
that doesn't mean as actors they can't
bring the fight to be
or not
it's like an acting exercise isn't it
while holland and bonham carter was a
lot nicer to gary oldman when the
cameras weren't rolling
she did make sure he knew to let her do
her thing when she was in the moment and
if i start talking gary just let me
improvise stop you and that folks is how
someone goes from laughing in the middle
of takes to whipping out an unforgivable
curse
number four
and here we have an example of total
comic genius one of tom felton's
all-time best bloopers in the harry
potter saga was one that slipped under
the radar making the final cut because
it was just that good what line are we
referring to
didn't know you could read
yes that wasn't scripted felton totally
goofed losing his line in the moment and
trying to cover it up with this stalling
line we wonder if he knew back then that
it would become one of the most iconic
draco lines there is
number five
when is he not feisty is the real
question though jason isaacs knew he had
to bring all those evil malfoy family
vibes even when he was working opposite
literal kids
i come my way potter give him a cane and
he is set but at times he got a bit too
carried away and what was young daniel
supposed to do about it luckily isaacs
isn't actually that aggressive and
unpleasant
number six
screen you don't want to get in their
way off camera is another story
it's great that she calls me i feel very
honored that she kills me julie walters
and helena bonham carter well they're
two of the nicest actors around but you
wouldn't know what judging solely on
their big duel during the battle of
hogwarts she loves inflicting pain and
that's her only joy julie walters really
let herself go bringing all the
feistiness her red hair could muster up
to face off with a slytherin through and
through the one and only bellatrix who
was way more fun when the cameras
weren't rolling
number seven
anything can happen on broomsticks and
that includes mishearing whoops
yikes this slytherin was ready to bite
keep in mind this teasing was a bit more
elevated literally an actor could have
gone tumbling from their broomstick
easily maybe felton was just trying to
use the old method acting trick getting
into character any time he could but
don't worry he's also made it clear just
how he and radically felt about each
other
[Music]
we love each other
number eight
you don't want to cross a line with
draco otherwise he'll start throwing
insults your way
okay well at least that was the take we
saw what we didn't get so much of was
the enthusiasm tom felton actually had
for this moment
is it just us or does it seem like
felton enjoys it even more than david
bradley does
number nine
when voldemort is on screen he's gonna
milk every second of it he and ray finds
were similar in that way when the actor
was in the zone he let himself go
how lies a fed yoga
do you know where you're standing do you
know where you're standing it was
impressive to see just how fluid he was
messing up lines but always making sure
the camera caught loads of different
takes while feinz dug it and the editing
team had an amazing catalog of different
variations and takes from him poor
radcliffe did get the short end of the
stick on this one so he had to put up
with a lot from me
doing endless takes while he suffered
number ten
he did say touch nothing don't touch
draco and i hit him with that kane in
this scene that wound up being cut
felton got a bit more than he bargained
for from his oh-so-strict father jason
isaacs was familiar with the harry
potter books before he came on set as
lucius knowing just how vile the malfoy
family could be and he came to give him
what he deserved unfortunately felton
really did bear the brunt of it and i
went
top striker and the fangs went right
into his skin ouch we finished the scene
and i went tom i'm so sorry my nose was
good for the scene number 11
these sidekicks well there's something
crab and goyal what a pear throw some
mad eye moody into the mix and chaos is
sure to ensue throw in a prop creature
yeah these two could make a ruckus
jamie waylett and josh herdman tried to
keep composed but in the outtakes it
seems a lot more like neither of them
really knew what was going on while they
both looked more like they were just
tickling each other instead of helping
each other no wonder brendan gleason
couldn't resist letting a giggle slip
number 12
one small speaker can go a long way
what speaker you ask who knew just how
loudly that would echo into the hall
well alan rickman and michael gambin had
quite the laugh pranking a young
radcliff by setting off a fart machine
they had planted in a sleeping bag
throughout the scene to make matters
worse radcliffe was in very close
proximity to a girl that he had a crush
on in our dreams we enter completely
our own world
rickman was usually pretty good at
keeping his composure on set but he
couldn't resist this one and evidently
neither could the entire cast and crew
number 13.
give her an inch and she'll take a mile
even just hearing about the chance to
improvise in a scene don't be afraid to
go off script it doesn't matter just
don't be trying to go off script well
it's enough to get this slytherin
actress excitedly giggling we might hate
a lot of the things her character does
in the series but it's hard not to love
her performance
especially when her smile feels just a
bit less evil
number 14.
who could resist when he impresses like
this tom felton left the stiff draco
behind in favor of the dancing man who
partied up a storm filling the yule ball
scenes yeah man i've been doing my
sticks i've been working my feet this
goofing off behind the scenes worked in
his favor even tempting a gryffindor who
we never thought we'd see being anything
but loyal come on i'm gonna come over to
the dark side we dance with this
slytherin any day
number 15.
we wouldn't want to be in their
harnesses smiling now only because my
feet are on the floor yeah don't you
just hate that feeling when the floor
slips out from under you tom felton
couldn't even feign confidence doing
everything in his power to keep under
enough control for the scene
unfortunately even after going through
it over and over and over again it never
gets any easier it's an instinct you
know logic logic brain thing you can't
override it while they did some pretty
terrible things on screen
okay very terrible we're looking at you
voldemort luckily for the rest of the
cast and crew they weren't even close to
as nasty as their characters which
outtake was your favorite
[Music]
[Music]
you